aquí tenemos a bs de un rombo y lo que
queremos probar es que el área del rombo
el área de abc d es igual a ac por b de
entre 2 o sea básicamente queremos ver
que para determinar el área de un rombo
podemos simplemente tomar el semi
producto de las diagonales vale bueno
vamos a acordarnos de todo lo que
sabemos acerca de los rombos los rombos
para empezar son figuras de cuatro lados
en los cuales los cuatro lados son
iguales entonces aquí tenemos que ave es
igual a b c que es igual a c de que es
igual a de a pero los rombos además de
ser rombos son paralelo gramos es decir
los padres opuestos de lado son
paralelos y de los paralelogramo sabemos
varias cosas sabemos que las diagonales
se visitan entre sí entonces vamos a
utilizar eso y déjame llamarle a este el
punto vale entonces lo que sabemos es
que hay
es igual a ese a ese y además sabemos
que b b es igual a de vale las
diagonales se secan entre sí y no sólo
eso además demostramos en el vídeo
pasado que las diagonales también son
perpendiculares cuando tenemos un roma
entonces aquí es perpendicular aquí es
perpendicular todos estos ángulos que
estoy marcando son de 90 grados vale muy
bien entonces ahora sí vamos a pensar un
poquito en el plan para intentar mostrar
que el área es el semi producto de las
diagonales la idea va a ser dividir este
rombo en dos triángulos congruentes el
abc y el adc
si logramos ver que son congruentes y
encontramos el área de uno va a estar a
multiplicar esa área por dos para
encontrar el área de todo el rombo
entonces vamos a empezar con eso vamos a
observar que el triángulo abc abc es
congruente al triángulo adc adc y estoy
aquí es por criterio por criterios de
congruencia lado lado lado porque porque
tenemos que ave es igual a ade que bc es
igual a cd
más comparten este lado el lado hace
vale muy bien entonces eso está padre
porque ahora el área del cuadrilátero
abc de el área de abc de la podemos
partir en dos áreas la del triángulo a b
c más el área del triángulo a de c
de c pero utilizando esta información de
aquí arriba podemos juntar estas dos en
una misma y poner que esto es igual a
dos veces el área del triángulo a veces
vale porque a veces y adc son triángulos
congruentes y entonces ya nada más
tenemos que determinar el área del
triángulo apc déjame tomar el color
amarillo es decir queremos determinar
esta área de acá y bueno para determinar
el área de un triángulo hay que hacer
base por altura entre dos entonces lo
voy a poner por aquí el área del
triángulo abc es igual a base por altura
entre 2 y la base quien sería pues nos
conviene pensar hace como base porque
aquí hay una perpendicular que va a
funcionar
entonces va a ser igual a hace esa es la
base eso hay que multiplicarlo por b
v
y esto lo tenemos que dividir entre 2
dividir entre 2 y ahora lo que voy a
hacer que un poquito fea esta vez la voy
a arreglar lo que voy a hacer es ver a
ver cómo la mitad dvd si porque ve es
igual a ed entonces ve es la mitad debe
de entonces de esta forma podemos
escribir esta igualdad como hace hace x
dvd por un medio debe de dvd y esto lo
dividimos entre 2 entre 2 y entonces
ahora si regresamos al área de el
cuadrilátero a b c d es decir juntamos
esta información con la que tenemos aquí
abajito entonces el área del
cuadrilátero del cuadrilátero bcb es
igual a 2 veces el área del triángulo
abc pero la tenemos aquí déjame ponerle
un paréntesis entonces es 2 por esta
expresión esta expresión es hace
y hace
por bebé por vd de aquí hay una entre
dos aquí hay un entre dos entonces esto
es entre cuatro entre cuatro cerramos el
paréntesis y ya nada más simplificamos
verdad 2 entre 4 nos queda 2 abajo y
entonces esto de aquí es igual a hace
por bebé
entre dos muy bien entonces con esto
demostramos que en un rombo podemos
multiplicar las diagonales y dividir
entre dos para obtener el área y eso
está muy padre verdad bueno ya sabíamos
que el rombo en un paralelogramo y
teníamos en otro vídeo una fórmula para
el área de los paralelogramo que
básicamente era base por altura pero
ahora tenemos este que es un resultado
pues también bonito por sí mismo que
otra forma de obtener el área de un
rombo es multiplicar sus diagonales y
dividir eso entre 2